good morning John today we're gonna be
doing something a little bit different
I'm gonna be holding a debate here in my
house around the topic of net neutrality
featuring me an internet user and me
representing a cable company on opposite
sides of the table literally first
things first for the viewers at home I
think we should just define what net
neutrality is sounds like a fine place
to begin so net neutrality is the idea
that Internet service providers should
provide access to all of the Internet at
the same speed no matter what content it
is no one gets any preference fair
definition the question is is that a
good idea like why should I an Internet
service provider have to provide
gameofthrones via BitTorrent at the same
speed as I provided through HBO go oh
okay you're not a law enforcement agency
and that's not your job
but like you shouldn't be determining
how your users use your service it's the
Internet you just provide access to it
and but like my concern is that if you
do it to BitTorrent that you'll do it
too like a legitimate competitor to your
business like Netflix for example
no-one's talking about doing that you
say that but yeah they are like Comcast
literally slowed down Netflix's internet
connection and force them to pay to get
faster access to their customers like it
happened all the random flicks is
responsible for over 30% of the
bandwidth use in the u.s. why should all
of our customers regardless of whether
they use Netflix be required to pay for
the massive infrastructure upgrades
necessary to provide that service
of course Netflix should pay but we're
not talking about slowing down Netflix
to make them pay we're just saying we're
gonna speed Netflix up if they do panic
if you sped Netflix up without adding it
in your bandwidth didn't you
definitionally slow someone else down in
order to speed Netflix up you are right
now for the first time in American
history making the internet and on level
playing fields you talked high and
mighty about economic efficiency but
what creates great economies is not
profit it's competition which is what
you're trying to destroy I mean the
Internet's a mature industry now we
can't keep running around like it's 1998
hey be fun feel good times it's time to
buckle down and turn this thing into a
real economic engine we want to charge
customers for access to content and
charge content companies for access to
the customers we get paid twice it's
great for
Russ the internet is not your business
model the Internet is a massive
technological and economic and cultural
force for good that everyone should have
equal access to and your place as a
middle man does not decree through
magical powers to extract value would
have returned you have no right to
decide what information goes at what
speed through your pipes and the only
though I mean we're already doing it
with Netflix we're kind of already set
the precedent let's face it this is a
complicated legal thing and with the
potential upside for us we can afford a
lot of lawyers and lobbyists no offense
but I don't think you can plan on our
level guess we'll see John I'll see you
on Tuesday hi I'm a little bit worried
about this
I want the internet to remain open and
neutral in America first selfish and
also altruistic reasons who can help and
please do the FCC is currently asking
for comments please go to comment at the
FCC's website there's a link in the
description tell them to classify
broadband internet as a common carrier
service which will prevent telecoms from
making the internet a closed non neutral
place do you want to have more long term
ways in the description there are a few
organizations that are working on these
issues actually hiring lawyers and
lobbyists to compete with the telecoms
you can give them money you can give
them your time you can give them your
action and you can call your Congress
people I love the internet a lot and I
bet that you do too and I am worried
what's gonna happen if we let the
middlemen decide what the internet is
like frankly I don't trust them